[تصفيق]
ابتسم دائما انا رجل سعيد فانا محظوظ
بانني العب في نادي رائع ولعائله رائعه
لدي اربعه اولاد وانا بصحه جيده واملك كل
شيء
الفائز بخمس جوائز كره ذهبيه ومحطما الرقم
القياسي استحق الجائزه هذا العام كنت
استحق اكثر العام الفائت انا سعيد وما
مجموعه 29 جائزه وطنيه انه فوزي الاول في
دوري الابطال شعوري مذهل كما تعلمون انها
لحظه رائعه واكثر من 700 هدف خلال مسيرته
الكرويه وهذا جزء مما حققه خلال مسيرته
الكرويه الاحترافيه العالميه على مدى 17
عاما يعرف كل ارقام ريال مدريد القياسيه
ولا يزال يحرز الاهداف لاعبون مذهلون
ساعده ابداعه وسرعته ورؤيته الحالمه في ان
يصبح واحدا من اعظم اللاعبين في التاريخ
استعدوا دائما بالطريقه نفسها لا يهم
الفريق الذي سالعب ضده يبقى تركيزي
بالمستوى نفسه دائما
من فريق سبورتنج لشبونه البرتغالي الى
مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزي الى ريال مدريد
الاسباني مرحبا يا
مدريد والان فريق يوفنتوس الايطالي اظهر
رونالدو انه لا يستطيع اي شيء ابقاء فما
يزال يقدم اداء يستحق الجوائز اسبوعا بعد
اسبوع انه واحد من اعظم لاعبين في التاريخ
ولا احد يستطيع الاعتراض على ذلك ابدا
شاهدوا رحلتنابغه البرتغال وقصه حصوله على
لقب بطل العالم
انا سعيد لكن لا يستطيع احد التنبؤ انه
الرجل صاحب لقب سي ار 7 اريد الاستمرار
على هذا النحو عاما بعد عام انه
كريستيانو رونالدو
[موسيقى]
ولد كريستيانو رونالدو دوس سانتوس افيرو
في الخامس من فبراير عام
1985 وهو الاصغر بين اخوته الاربعه كانت
والدته تعمل الطاهيه وكان والده بستانيا
المدينه
عاشت عائلته في مدارا التي اصبحت الان
وجهه سياحيه ذات شعبيه كبيره وهي جزيره
صغيره قباله الساحل البرتغالي لكن في
العام
1985 كانت مدارس في فقر متقع ويسكنها
مجتمع صغير جدا ذكر رونالدو ان عائلته
عاشت حياه متواضعه خاليه من البفخ والرخاء
بكل تاكيد ولد كريستيانو في عائله كبيره
جدا في جزيره ماديرا وكانت عائلته تعيش في
فونشال لا اعتقد انه يمكن القول انما ديرا
تقع في منتصف المحيط الاطلسي فهذا غير
صحيح لكنها بعيده جدا عن بر البرتغال
الرئيسي فذلك لا يشبه الترعرع في لشبونه
او بورتو او احدى المدن الرئيسيه بل
الحياه فيها جدا عن البر البرتغالي
الرئيسي فهو مجتمع صغير جدا وكان رونالدو
يلعب كره القدم هناك مع عائلته واصدقائه
في شوارع ماديرا وانخرط مع النادي المحلي
كان والده يعمل مدير معدات بدوام جزئي لدى
النادي المحلي لذا ولد في عائله لها موطئ
قدم في اللعبه اذا تربى على يد اب عاشق
لكره القدم وهو امر شديد الاهميه بالطبع
بالنسبه الى كريستيانو الصغير حين بدا
يشحذ مهاراته في شوارع فونشال كان في نادي
الشباب المحلي يكتسب مهاراته الكرويه وكان
يشعر كانه على بعد ملايين الكيلومترات عن
اضواء الانديه الاوروبيه الساطعه التي
يطمح لان يلعب معها
في سن الثامنه انضم رونالدو الى فريق
الشباب الاول له وهو فريق اندورينا حيث
كان والده يعمل مدير معدات بدوام جزئي
اصبحت كره القدم الان هوسا بالنسبه اليه
وكان يمارسها في الشوارع والملعب على
السواء في سن العاشره انتقل الى واحد من
اكبر النوادي في ماديرا وهو نادي ناسيونال
لكن اثناء اللعب مع النادي اكتشفه مكتشف
مواهب كره قدم وفي سن 12 تم اختياره ليقدم
تجربه اداء للانضمام الى الفريق البرتغالي
سبورتنج لشبونه
اعتقد ان موهبه رونالدو الفذه كانت واضحه
منذ سن مبكره كانت واضحه لعائلته وزملائه
في الفريق وجميع من حوله وعلى الرغم من ان
ماديرا بعيده جدا عن بر البرتغال الرئيسي
الا ان النوادي الكبيره في بر البرتغال
الرئيسي كانت على درايه بما يحصل وكانوا
متحمسين للذهاب والاستعلام عن شخص يتسبب
بكل هذه الضجه حتى لو كان في جزيره ماديرا
الواقعه في عرض المحيط الاطلسي وعندما كان
رونالدو في سن 12 دعاه فريق سبورتنج الى
لشبونه هل يمكنكم تخيل حجم الانتقال من
جزيره ماديرا الصغيره جدا والتي تعد مجرد
بركه صغيره جدا ليجد فجاه انه اخذ الى
سبورتنج الذي لديه اكاديميه خاصه به
بالقرب من لشبونه وانتقل كريستيانو الى
البر الرئيسي وهو صبي في سن الثانيه عشره
او 13 الامر يشبه الهجره الى بلد مختلف
بالكامل يتكلم اللغه نفسها انه البلد نفسه
لكن الطابع مختلف جدا عن ط وجد رونالدو
نفسه وهو في سن 12 يعيش في العاصمه
البرتغاليه ومنظما الى اكاديميه سبورتنج
لشبونه هذه الى مجتمع ذاك النادي الكبير
البعيد كل البعد عن كل ما كان معتادا عليه
وتوجب عليه العيش مستعينا بذكائه وموهبته
وبالطبع كان يتمتع بالموهبه الكافيه ليلمع
نجمه على الفور لكن لم يكن الانتقال الى
البر الرئيسي سهلا على رونالدو فقد عن ذلك
ان عليه العيش بعيدا عن عائلته وذكر ان
الايام الاولى كانت صعبه وانه شعر بالحنين
الى الديار كل يوم لكن استمر رونالدو
بتطوير مسيرته مع فريق سبورتنج لشبونه كان
رونالدو لاعبا محوريا ضمن فريق سبورتنج
لشبونه للشباب كان تنافسيا وماهرا جدا
وكانت موهبته واضحه لكل من حضر المباريات
كما ذكر زملائه في الفريق ان قدرته
واسلوبه في اللعب كان مختلفين عن كل ما
راوه سابقا
كان يملك ميزه خاصه وكان من الواضح انه
نجم اخذ في الصعود لوحظت موهبته هذه مبكرا
جدا من قبل فريق سبورتنج ولم يمضي وقت
طويل قبل ان تبدا مسيرته بالازدهار
عندما كنت صبيا صغيرا كنت اشعر دائما
انني مميز وليس من وجهه نظري فقط بل رايت
الناس ينظرون الي بطريقه مختلفه لانني
اعتقد انني كنت مختلفا عن بقيه اللاعبين
[موسيقى]